Trump watches a lot of news he watches a
lot of cable news more so then we don't
know how much other presidents watched
the news and maybe they watched it
selectively but Trump is a huge consumer
of the news and he's up all night and
he's watching TV and we know that for a
fact and we even know what new shows
he's watching and who we know that which
ones he's screaming at he's screaming oh
yeah you're aware then that when you're
on television there's at any given
moment a 20% chance that the president
United States is watching you
well I mean and and yelling at the
screen and throwing his submarine
sandwich at it or how do you feel about
that do you find that unnerving well no
I mean it's it's not a mystery because
he's usually tweeting back right that's
right I mean that's how we know right
and you know he's usually watching Fox
right and you know he's happy with that
he likes Fox and Friends right got some
friends yeah that's his favorite show
right Teletubbies
we know that on the born our morning
show a new day we do and you know he is
often watching that and you will be
talking about something and he'll he'll
be tweeting about it and it's I mean in
some respects I think it's kind of great
actually that he is you know engaged and
talking about you know these issues I
think some of the tweets would be better
if they were a little less crazy but but
the fact that I love that that's how far
we've lowered they are loving the tweets
if some of them were insane yeah but all
the better
yeah also the spelling not the best
right but you know spellcheck I think is
available in the white house and I think
you should take it I do think he is a he
is one of the things that people who are
supporters say that they really like
about him is that he feels like he's
true to himself he is an accurate
representation of what a lot of 70 year
old man trying to tweet I do think and
that's how you get the Fifi or he still
has a VCR fast flashing 12 yeah it's
better over and over again just a
reference that anyone under 40 doesn't
even yeah
you